what an episode Danny
I honestly was on the edge of my seat
the entire episode now that it's all out
there
friends family survivor fans have seen
it all how are you feeling today
I feel great it was like an incredible
Adventure like really incredible
Adventure uh yeah I have absolutely no
regrets so like I left no stone unturned
and uh I tried my very best so uh I try
not to get attached to the results to
attach to the journey and the journey
was incredible so I have no complaints
oh that's amazing to hear now I have to
ask you you were very convinced like
Heidi convinced you that she was not the
one that that voted for you in the
previous Tribal Council is it because
you guys were such close allies that you
were like I trust her 100 or was there
ever a moment of Doubt
um that maybe it was her
no I it was never about
um trust from age it to me is again this
necessity I never trusted anybody when
it came to gameplay like uh if it was
came to like Heidi like you know
watching my daughter I would have 100
trust uh in every single thing but when
it comes to who you vote for it's like
you can't go by trust fat because like
what's gonna Propel her game
so at the time I didn't logically see
like I'm trying to break down like okay
how does it behoove her how does hoover
I couldn't find the angle how hooped her
at the time now that being said if the
vote went the other way and and it and
and I went home instead of Franny which
very easily could have happened then it
would have been a really smart move uh
but it just so happened it was it wasn't
the it not that it wasn't a smart move
it wasn't the right move so at the time
I was having trouble finding that and
also I wasn't really overly concerned
with figuring out the truth
um because I didn't really think it
mattered because if she did I didn't
really have much many like uh I I keep
telling me golf tournament and I said
hey Heidi can we get back on the same
page now uh you know like uh she's like
I didn't vote on you so I'm like
yeah okay and so I believed here uh uh
also because it wouldn't have changed
anything like I wouldn't I wouldn't have
changed my game like we still voted the
same
uh you know uh the same way I I wouldn't
have uh went and started a plot against
Heidi uh for what so then we could have
I wanted to get a ticket no matter what
absolutely definitely they made it clear
that the artique is strong moving in to
the next episode but I quickly have to
ask you about the immunity challenge
because it is a Survivor classic now
being out there for 21 22 days
how
does that challenge specifically take
both a physical and mental toll on you
because from a viewer's point of view
you're like oh yeah I think I could do
that but then watching it and continuing
it I'm like oh gosh I could never do
that but what's it like actually doing
it it always surprised by it was very
difficult
um I when I came up from you know being
underwater I I thought that I would
either be I thought I was gonna win I
felt like I thought or maybe coming up
right before or I was shocked to see
Heidi and uh Jam Jam still killing it
um I couldn't breathe
um and
Jam Jam said something uh
uh at one point you know when Jeff was
interviewing he said
I knew that that Survivor keeps us safe
I had a hundred percent uh faith in the
Survivor of safety protocols and
everything I knew they wouldn't let me
die uh but I was not coming like I was
not coming up and I'm like wow not just
a testament to like jams mental
fortitude and how much of a badass he is
he was like I'll tell you I didn't go in
with that I I definitely went in
thinking like I probably cannot last
everybody he went in thinking I'm not
being I'm not choosing to come up I'll
either pass out or or or or win anyone
so that's just a testament to like like
you know when he gave that that fired me
up give me like a little Goosebumps like
you know um
and yeah it was impressive I just I love
watching people do they you know
obviously I wish it was me but I like
watching people doing messy stuff
yeah it was it's every time that
challenge goes I'm just even more and
more impressed with everyone on that
show
um now after that when you guys you know
go back to Camp I mean Jim is one
immunity you know you guys are have you
Lauren Heidi Jamie and you're all having
discussions about you know Carson should
be the one to go and then you have
Carolyn coming up to you being like so
what's the plan what's the plan and you
know she you told her kind of
a plan obviously wasn't the one you guys
had said but when she walked away were
you convinced that she believed you or
did you were you like oh okay like I
don't think she believes me
uh
I didn't particularly care
um I didn't know
uh like I I thought because I and what I
said to her was
not this phone let's go next photo we'll
go Carson so like I didn't just go like
no never go after Carson I was like all
right no not this vote let's go after
you you're right he is a threat but
let's go next if if it goes this way we
can still go next vote and uh I knew
that one of my plan was to work with
Tikka one of them uh you know after
uh because I was gonna probably Target
either Heidi or uh not really sure what
I was gonna do yet but you know I was
not committed to any like Alliance or
anything like that anybody who knows me
knows it I had no connectivity towards
like you know like uh you know sticking
with any plan but uh yeah I didn't know
she had an idol uh and
uh I also knew like it really wasn't
I didn't count on her vote like I I uh I
counted on like who did I need to
convince I need to convince Warren and
Jamie so like that's what I was really
you know you know dedicating my time
towards
now before we get to that
vote of Lauren and Jamie
is when you
uh you know you are casting your boats
and Carolyn takes I don't know how long
but like once through your head and also
how long was she actually up there like
kind of realistically or guessing
it was a long time
uh
yeah I was trying I don't know it's
doing prep work or kind of just
things fast the time like you know we're
not allowed to talk
so
uh but yeah it was a long time and then
you know you know it's cow it's a cow is
going to do things Cowan's way so
she was being hurt and just having and
having a having a good time uh
figuring things out up there
oh my gosh that's hilarious because just
watching everyone's faces I was like oh
my gosh I wonder what is going through
their head right now like what is taking
her so long
yeah crazy
yeah so fast forward to obviously you
getting sent home
um and then we see as viewers that both
Jamie and Lauren voted for Heidi when
you saw those votes come through how
surprised were you that it was split
that way
did you think that you had them in your
corner yeah I didn't think it made sense
for them at the time you know I didn't
think it made sense for them to not now
now instead of being too like you know
from my earlier gameplay that I liked to
even the playing field you know uh it
was three three and three from the idle
play
um
uh
and now it would have been two two and
two so
um it would have been straight to Tikka
two Soca two right two um cool like
let's you know it's basically starting
the game over
but uh you know uh conversations
Communications were had that
uh you know to
dad may not be the case yeah
um I also have to applaud you for your
amazing exit on the show how did your
family and friends react to that oh they
they love it they uh we scored I uh it's
a my general face is something that they
had they have me do all the time uh I'll
be out like at a bar and stuff like that
but Danny Jenny Daniel face him all
right well this this thing yeah huh you
want me to De Niro face too huh
Entertainment Weekly Canada you want the
Daniel phase two you're gonna get it
hahaha
that's great it was honest honestly like
one of the highlights of the episode
despite you being sent home like
obviously we don't like that we don't
like that but I appreciate it
I appreciate how you
um and lastly I just want to ask you
because you know Jeff asked Carson about
this last night but what would you say
was the biggest takeaway or the biggest
thing you learned about yourself from
being on the show
um being disconnected from
society and cell phones and just away
from my wife away from my kid away from
my niece and nephews and uh you know my
mom and dad my sister uh I just uh
uh put things perspective like don't
waste time your hand you're not
passionate about and uh yeah I you know
but I really found out out there from
doing breath work on the beach every day
with Franny I'm like super passionate
about that and meditation and like uh
kind of cut out a lot of stuff out of my
life that I am not passionate about uh
and uh put that time and effort into
things I am passionate about
oh that's lovely I love hearing these
stories they're such heartwarming things
that you've learned about yourself on
the show well thank you so much for
chatting with me today and we know we
still get you on the jury we'll see yeah
I hope there's some great outfits that's
what I'm counting on but oh you know it
girl
we we know it all right